[music]
Oh JK Rowling
What are you doin' with your time?
What are you doin’ with your time?
Givin' all your money to charity and I guess
that sounds just fine,
But I’m wonderin’ if you got just a couple
more jots.
Givin' all your money to charity and I guess
that sounds just fine,
But I'm wonderin' if you got just a couple
more jots.
Maybe you could, I dunno, crack a laptop.
Oh do it as a favor to me!
Do it for the kids or do it for charity!
Yeah! Do it for the HPA!
Oh I don't really care, just do it today!
[music]
I'm giving you absolute creative freedom.
Maybe you could write up a screen play,
Or a prequel musical for Broadway,
Or collaborate on a comic with Joss Whedon,
Or a miniseries for the BBC,
Any of that sounds good to me.
I suggest you avoid cartoons
Or giving Fox a chance to cancel you.
And after considering this one pretty carefully
Please don't make an MMORPG,
Cause that totally destroy my productivity
SO!
Oh JK Rowling
What are you doin' with your time?
Givin' all your money to charity and I guess
that sounds just fine,
But I'm wonderin' if you got just a couple
more jots.
Maybe you could, I dunno, crack a laptop.
Oh do it as a favor to me!
Do it for the kids or do it for charity!
Yeah! Do it for the HPA!
Oh I don't really care just do it
I don't really care just do it
No I don't really care just do it today!
[music]
Just so you know, that is the shortest song
on the album. It's not an album full of minute
and thirty second long songs. It- They're
mostly normal length. I do have a special
place in my heart for really short songs,
so I really like that one.
That video was made by Risa Rodil whose work
you may know from all of her amazing things
that she puts on tumblr. And thank you to
Michael and Stefan who came over late last
night to help me with the dancing parts. I
don't know how to use After Effects.
Incongruent is officially released! It is
in the world now; it is available on iTunes,
and Google Play, and Amazon, and at DFTBA
Records where you can get physical copies.
And also if you get a physical copy you will
get a download link. Just...get them both
ways. Unfortunately, due to my own idiocy,
the clean version is not going to be shipping
out of the warehouse for another couple of
weeks yet. Sorry. There was a mistake. But
they WILL be signed, if you pre-ordered them.
We've also finished booking the entire tour,
so you can now get tickets at every single
one of the stops including Pomona, which is
nearby Los Angeles, but not quite Los Angeles.
San Francisco, Eugene, Portland, Seattle,
Boise, Denver, and Salt Lake City. I think
I switched those last two. A couple of the
venues have changed so make sure you check
and don't go to the wrong place.
Hank Green and the Perfect Strangers will
also be playing at VidCon. VIDCOOOOOOOON.
Which reminds me if you haven't got your VidCon
tickets yet, you need to do that right now
because we're 95% sold out and I would love
for as many nerdfighters to be there as possible,
because I like you.
If you aren't aware of what VidCon is, it's
an annual meet-up of people who love online
video, uh, with concerts and panels and discussions
of the culture and business of online video
and performances and Q&As and signings, and
it's generally a really fun time. It's in
Anaheim, and it's from June 26th to June 28th.
So three days of VidCon this year, guys. I'm
super excited about it. I am ALSO super overwhelmed
by it, but that's life.
To people who don't live in the Western United
States: I'm sorry. It's hard to get away for
more than a couple of weeks when you have
SciShow and Crash Course and all the other
projects and people that we need to keep happy
and healthy here in Missoula. I like making
those things for the internet because everyone
can have them no matter where you live, but
if you ARE in the Western United States: lucky
duck. The rest of you - I'm here, on the internet,
always.
Hope you like this song. John, I'll see you
on Tuesday.